هو شغل الشاغل للبريطانيين وحديث الشارع
الاكثر اثاره للنقاش والحوارات المحتدله
هل تستولي تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي على
وظائفنا ام هل تفتح حقبه جديده من
الازدهار البشري هل مخاوف الناس منطقيه ام
انها تعيد سيناريوهات الماضي المتخوفه
دائما من التقدم التكنولوجي
68% من الشركات الكبرى في العالم بدات
بدمج تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي في خدماتها
15% من الشركات البريطانيه اعتمدت شكلا من
اشكال الذكاء الاصطناعي ومن المتوقع ان
يشهد الذكاء الاصطناعي معدل النمو سنوي
باكثر من سبعه وثلاثين في المئه من عام
2023 حتى عام 2030
[موسيقى]
اصوات المحذره من الذكاء الاصطناعي فقد
ازدادت في الاونه الاخيره خاصه بين اصحاب
الجيل الاكبر الذي قد يصعب عليه التاقلم
مع سرعه تقدم التقنيات الجديده نواب
بريطانيون دعوا الى ضروره وضع ضوابط على
التقنيات المستخدمه خاصه مع توقعات
بنديفار 7% من جميع الوظائف خلال الخمس
سنوات المقبله
سبعه في المئه من جميع الوظائف البريطانيه
قد تخرج عن الخدمه بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي
من ان يتسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي في فقدان
وظائفهم فيما تشير توقعات الدراسه الى ان
تقنيات اي اي او الذكاء الاصطناعي ستؤثر
على خمسه عشر في المئه من القوه العامله
في العالم
ان تتحكم تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي بوظائف
الخدمه العملاء والوظائف التي تتطلب
التعامل مع الاشخاص والوظائف الممله ساكون
سعيدا برؤيه ذلك يحدث
لكن ليس كل ما يحيط بالذكاء الاصطناعي يعد
مثيرا للقلق متحمسون للتقنيه وجهدوا فرصه
في دمج الذكاء الاصطناعي في خدماتهم
المؤسسات التعليميه اول المستفيدين حيث
تتيح تقنيات اي اي مثلا في اخذ الطلاب في
جولات افتراضيه لحقب تاريخيه ماضيه او
التجول داخل جسم افتراضي في صف البيولوجيا
كما تقدم التقنيه الفرصه لتوفير معلم شخصي
لكل تلميذ واخت قبيل الامتحانات
رغم المخاوف والحاجه الملحه لوضع ضوابط
على تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي الا انه لا
يمكن الانكار ان اي اي يتيح المزيد من
الوقت ويقلل من الجهد البشري لانجاز بعض
المهام كما قد يدفع البشر الى تطوير
مهارات قد تغير وجه العالمي للابد من ننظر
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات